good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy
hump day and merch day it's so many
important days
wrapped in one and it's my anniversary
oh yes my two-year wedding anniversary
it's such a busy day i was so
overwhelmed this morning because we have
the merch shop which is already live
it's already sickening your shopping
carts down
some of the products are so low
inventory we're gonna have to put the
future orders on pre-order so
make sure you head over to
shopmorningtoast.com not
shopper maze and certainly not chop
chanel i know it's confusing for people
shop morning toast.com the howie dern
collection phone cases
beanies sweatshirts the redheads
collection
mugs notebooks sweatshirts everything
did i forget anything everything i just
want to show off my long sleeve because
it hasn't been wearing it on the show
it's a toast exclusive
it's a brown long sleeve a little
chocolate brown i would say so too
with a little small how you turn emblem
on the chest
and i'm wearing the bone crew neck in
the how you turn collection i'm just
obsessed with the collection like this
lasso like find me at stagecoach
wearing my hyuderne bone crew neck a
hundred percent when it gets a little
chilly at night
oh i'm ready for luke homes let me grab
my bone sweatshirt how you doing luke
cohen how you
darn lou combs so it's all very exciting
and make sure you get your merch
asap so that no one else does yeah we um
are very excited about the drop so thank
you to everyone who has purchased
and is loving thank you to the redheads
who are showing up and showing out i
obviously knew that like
since it's my passion project like i
figured my passions would overflow and
spill out towards other people but like
the redheads are just showed up in
droves this morning and i just love you
guys so much no and honestly
i feel like it's a huge lesson in
passion it
is like and it's really that old adage
like if you do what you if you if you do
it love what you do
you love what you do you'll never work a
day in your life and i'm telling you
like the redheads does not work to me
like it's just
fun it's also that old adage like
passion projects
are passionate yes that old adage um
secret projects i'm sorry passion
projects over secret projects yeah it's
also that um
old adage i don't know if you've heard
this one that
merch is available at
shopmorningtoast.com have you heard that
i have heard that it's like kind of um
like super niche and like yeah it's very
actually it's very old school yeah i
think it's originally like a translated
proverb from yiddish yes a merch
available at
shopmorningtoast.com is the translation
i think
yeah we'll have to check ourselves um we
have a great show for you guys today
here's what we got
it's wednesday so we got the fast five
stories because the world is turning and
you must be informed it's super
important
we've got the real housewives of dallas
recap which i watched this morning and
it was actually very good
we've got deer toasters which is our
advice segment which we do every
wednesday here you write into
deertoasters gmail.com and
we'll answer your problems we got three
quandaries that's the right word yeah
three quandaries this week that could
use our help so we
will we're on the way call an ambulance
call an ambulance but not for you guys
because we have deer toasters coming at
you
um we also assigned yesterday our toast
movie of the week
and we got so much all of my friends
were texting me they were like oh my god
i used to watch that movie as a kid
and you haven't been able to find the
cinderella version with brandy and
whitney houston on any streaming
services but disney
plus finally like refurbished it renewed
the digital
whatever and put it out and every i'm so
excited to watch it i'm so excited to
watch it it's a great week of content
it's just a great week of toast it's
always an exciting week when there's
a marchy week a short week and another
birthday oh it's true you know
i'm getting my botox this afternoon like
that's
exciting well more exciting for your
anniversary but still something for me
too
yeah no the anniversary is exciting
we're going to dinner um are you going
to the restaurant i told you to go to i
am going to the restaurant you told me
to go to i'm very excited
also it's like a little no it's still
exciting i'm just a little bummed
because yesterday i restarted
keto like in a major way like i went to
barnes and noble like
pull my arm i had to go back oh my god
we we're literally this is turning into
a barnes and noble like
stan show and i agree so i went and i
got some keto cookbooks because i really
want to still be able to cook because
that's so fun but like make it
um within the keto guidelines because
i'm ready to turn
i'm ready to turn it around you know
i've gotten to ready to
turn the meat around
let you hear potatoes no no potatoes
okay sorry
turn them upside down
yeah um that's exciting like for you
it's it's not but it's nice to like have
a plan
and know that if i stick to it i'll get
where i'm where i want to be going
because this year has just been
rough on my on my health no you are
trimming down and i'm literally
expanding as we sit here so i just feel
like this is a really balanced show
yeah no but i feel like if you look at
the air as a whole like i've been
expanding
and you've been trimming down um like
definitely not no i feel like you look
great
well that's really nice and like of you
to lie like it's really nice i don't
really care like
it's just i think it's important that we
always stay balanced and i think
when you're the host and i'm the host
like balance is never a problem
yeah but i think sometimes it it you
know it's like this i guess
yes no it's it's like the scale of
justice thank you you know i couldn't
think of the phrase
um i want to say two things really
quickly so one was
make sure to watch cinderella available
on disney plus we'll be recapping it on
friday
two in more black history month news so
i've been doing cameos
um and donating 100 of my proceeds to
equal justice initiative which we
learned about
last year when we watched just mercy as
a community and i was very impacted by
it
and i really thought we were gonna raise
like two three thousand dollars and
we're already at seven thousand dollars
and i like shared on my instagram that i
was um we reached
like seventy two hundred dollars and i
got another thousand dollars in orders
that i'm gonna do today so we're like i
feel like we might raise 10k
that's amazing and i like that's a lot
like that
that could actually like make a
difference 100 i'm very proud of you
thank you so if you want to book me
for a special event birthday
bachelorette party anything cameo
search me growth no job 100 of the
proceeds going to equal justice
initiative
for the entire month and we're only
halfway through so like maybe i could
get to like 14 000. i don't know just an
idea
that's amazing oh and the second thing i
wanted to say was i had such an
interesting experience last night that i
was just telling you about
um i was up super late on this zoom that
i got booked for like super last minute
and i'm excited for everyone to see
because it was this um like jewish it
was for charity and it was like a jewish
event
um retelling the story of purim because
perham's at the end of the month
and they had jewish comedians like from
all over the country put together there
was this great script that was written
like it was modernized
modernizing the story of permanent i
mean the script was so funny
the script was so fun and claudia and i
were running lines we were crying i was
crying laughing like it was really well
done and on zoom
everyone got on and like did a table
read and they're going to stitch it
together for youtube
but it was like jeff garland bob saget
howie mandel
claudia and it was actually so much fun
it was supposed to take like 30 minutes
like everyone was just like cracking
jokes like every two seconds
and i actually had a great time like i
didn't mind being up till one which is
crazy for me no it sounds
so fabulous and it really was i thought
it was gonna be live last night i was
gonna tune in to watch because the
script was so good
and the cast is so good i literally and
it's such a great idea i mean if you
don't know the story of purim which
most people probably don't it's actually
a great story
i agree um one that is just very deeply
interesting so
whenever it comes out please share that
with us because i was live too
i'd love a purim refresher i messed oh
and i got a huge refresher but i
literally like messaged the
one of the people and i'm like hey like
where can i tell people to tune in like
i need to send to my family
she was like it's not live so like i was
like thank god i didn't send you guys a
zoom link that i had
because imagine you like showed up to
the private zoo like
so funny um but it'll be out by the end
of the month and i actually am really
excited about it because i think i did a
good job of
playing zeshar haman's wife a very
important role a very important role a
small role but
important no i think i'm sure you did a
great job it was i'm actually really
excited that it was just a
sweet treat yeah it was like a it was
like a fun little evening activity great
keep us posted on that we'll do we'll do
well i guess without further ado you
guess you know i don't know i feel like
there's so much more disgust like my
anniversary it really feels like my
birthday cause i'm getting tagged in so
many stories like of people
throwing back to the wedding which i'm
gonna do like a whole story later with
some of the highlights
um and maybe that's also what inspired
me to restart my keto journey like
seeing all those fabulous photos
my time up today was also like my
chiseled self
pictures from your wedding and it's just
like crazy what was it two years ago
a lifetime ago like don't know the girl
in that photo at all yeah
uh yeah it feels like a long time ago
and a short time ago especially because
this year is just you know in the
crapper yeah so it kind of just feels
like my one year
yeah that's actually crazy fifty percent
also marriage has been in quarantine for
sure but also like zach and i have spent
more time together this year than like
in ten years you've really been married
for 35 years exactly
yeah no that's that's math that's math
for you yeah guys that's what we do here
math math get off your assets do some
math math math
math math okay now that we've sang i
think it's time
yeah for the fast five story yeah it is
time for the past time stories that you
need to know before you wake up and take
a bite out of your morning toast
but not for me because i'm on keto well
you can have ezekiel bread
no i can't oh wow i could like make my
own bread with almond
flour according to these cookbooks oh
some people have too much time on their
hands
um today's episode is brought to you by
bruce to get those little brushes
those little pieces of toast out of your
teeth brush is the most
everyone knows we've been talking about
bruce forever people keep tagging me in
their stories
that they finally gave in ordered the
bruce and it has changed their life
it is they bet the best electric
toothbrush on the market it is very
reasonably priced
some of them can cost like over 200
dollars bruce does not it's very
reasonably priced
and it works as good better than any
i've ever used and i really mean that
the brush itself has six unique modes to
customize your brushing experience
the battery life lasts four weeks and it
comes with a magnetic charging stand and
a compact travel case
they also have a subscription program so
you never have to forget to change your
brush yet again
bruce ships your new replacement heads
every six months so you're never stuck
using a worn down brush head
their electric toothbrush has a modern
aesthetically pleasing design and it
comes in trend driven seasonal colors
and looks great on your bathroom counter
i know i feel like the last time we did
a a read for them i said i wanted to
look at the website and get maybe a new
one because i have like
millennial pink and it's super super
cute but i just want to see the new
seasonal trend driven colors
and i haven't done that so maybe i'll do
that today but it's really a fabulous
thing we both went to the dentist and
both got complimented on our brushing
uh skills and the doctor said what kind
of brush are you using i said doc
i'm not brushing i'm brushing if you
want to get 15
off your brush toothbrush kit and the
refill plan you can use the promo code
toast at bruce.com
that's 15 off using promo code toast at
b-r-u-u-s-h
dot com again that spelling is
b-r-u-u-s-h-dot-com
you won't regret it you know ask your
local toaster because she probably has a
brush
yeah a lot of people have been getting
brushes and it's just a premium
experience
it's a premium yeah yeah yeah yeah
first story love is in the air i feel
like with valentine's day having been
this weekend we're getting a lot of
celeb love news
right because maybe a lot of celebrities
like took the opportunity to like you
know make their relationship official
on valentine's day so we have some some
lovely news
first up paris hilton is engaged to
carter room
you know i actually feel like this could
be the one i really do he could be the
one
smooth talking so rocking
he's got everything that a girl's
wanting
to talk beauty he plays a groovy and i
can keep myself from saying something
stupid think i'm really falling for his
gun get butterflies when he says my name
he's got something special he's got
something special
and when he's looking at me i wanna get
all sentimental
he's got something special boom he's got
something special
and i can hardly believe something's
telling me telling me maybe he could be
the one
he could be the one you can tell me your
name i won't remember it i'll remember
that song till the day i die
and those are our thoughts on paris
hilton's engagement honestly it's really
all that needs to be said because he's a
smooth talker so
he is a venture capitalist it sounds
like she
found herself a businessman bo like
we've been recommending to all you
celebs all these years
she followed in the footsteps of caitlyn
bristow and that's really admirable
really admirable he proposed on a
private island on february 13th
after dating for about a year he popped
the question with an emerald cut diamond
ring designed by
jean-lucere
jean deuces oh john ducett i love his
work
[Laughter]
crying friends no john is
actually a good friend of mine he
actually goes by joe joe
okay so this is really exciting i agree
with you
could be the one and i just hope that it
is
me too especially because she was just
um in an interview when we spoke about
it on the top side she's really thinking
about
having kids motherhood so i don't know i
feel like
call me crazy i see a a rainbow ending
i do and though they're on a private
island i'll be building my ship
to get there yeah you can't fly there
commercially so you have to build your
own ship
yeah they actually yeah you have no
choice but to ship yeah look
literally no this is sweet um you know
as a close personal friend of paris
hilton i'm obviously thrilled for her
and i'm sure i'll be getting an invite
to the wedding you know any day now
yes for sure actually you know i did i
knew that she like told me already
kidding um are you ready for some more
lovebird news while we're on the topic
because kourtney kardashian has made it
instagram official with travis barker
jackie oh is eating her words yeah no
that was
that was i knew it was real but to see
it really real
well shocking i don't remember exactly
what i said but i feel as though i
wasn't a believer
like i i knew i was a doubter
non-believer
once were her dreamers
one of these days you'll open
i'm going to be annoying with singing
today i'm going to try and reel it in
sorry um
travis barker is dating kourtney
kardashian they posted a super cute
photo of their hands
interlocked i like her nails her nails
are sickening so romantic
and also they had been seen like having
dinner together but again the doubter
non-believer in me could have been like
their friends they're having dinner
um but this is super romantic and i'm
really
here for it and i'm impressed because i
think that kourtney kardashian has
atrocious taste in men like
i just always find myself not liking the
people that she dates i remember when
she did justin bieber
and scott has his stuff together now but
he was deeply problematic for a while
um eunice like beat the [ __ ] out of some
guy in an alley that video like haunted
me for years
but i actually i mean i don't know a lot
about travis parker maybe i'll find out
that i don't like him
but all the music he released with
machine gun kelly is excellent so so far
i'm a fan
yeah i feel like i've heard good things
about him so i'm sure
that this is actually a great couple for
you and ben no
machine gun kelly megan fox kourtney
kardashian travis parker like iconic
foursome maybe even better than machine
gun kelly megan fox
lala and randall why can't they be a six
some just four sums are just really more
i think they should they should be a six
some because it's always good to have
like a producer in the mix
yeah and like two reality stars i
actually feel like lala and courtney
would have a lot to say i feel like they
both like hate the reality life fame
i so agree i think they would all really
get along but i was going to say i think
this is a great couple for you and ben
to ship together
yeah he's like you love kardashians and
he loves rock music yeah no as much as
i've tried
to like get ben to care about things
that i care about like he would never
care
i think he might care about this give
him bring it up i'll bring it up i think
you guys could really bond over it i
will
i'm happy that they confirmed it i think
that this is like a nice couple and it's
actually been a while since courtney
dated someone like seriously and
publicly so
yeah there's hoping meanwhile i don't
even want to mention it but since we're
on the topic
of um yeah like a million scott being
seen together in miami like
still not okay with it not talking about
it um just want to let you guys know
yeah it's every time i see them it's
like super
it doesn't get it doesn't get more
appropriate yes it doesn't but maybe it
will because
we used to say the same [ __ ] about
sophia and scott i don't see myself
changing my tune on this one but you
never know literally last week i was
like against courtney and travis i think
i said i wouldn't build them a ship even
if it turned out to be true and look at
me
all aboard look at you you're right
paying for labor so i guess things can
change i just don't see that one
changing for me
yeah no i don't like that couple at all
yeah but
a little more kardashian news that i
find quite interesting i think that you
will too
kendall jenner announces that the launch
of her new tequila company
and it's already won some big awards
okay yesterday seemingly out of nowhere
the model announced her 818 tequila
brand
on instagram i just have to say if
you're an avid tick-tock user this was
not out of nowhere we've known about
this for a while you have why do you
share with me
oh okay so some girl um i'm blanking on
her name and i'm really sorry but she's
gotten she's already gotten credit from
kendall
she figured it out like she put together
all these screenshots of like
them drinking a lot of tequila recently
and there was a bottle in the back
of one of the pictures and like no one
would have noticed it but she put
together and she found the instagram
account that was private
and she blew it up it blew up on tick
tock drink818 the tequila
brand on instagram follows nobody except
for the girl who discovered it on tick
tock like they're really embracing it
because she was 100 right
wow she wasn't sure if it was kylie's
company or kendall's company
i think in the end she narrowed it down
to it being kendall's company
and now after like reading kendall's
post i actually think this is like
the smartest thing she could have done
no it sounds really brilliant the spirit
has been years in the making according
to the model and has already anonymously
won tasting competitions including the
world tequila awards you should um judge
one of those competitions
couldn't agree more for a variety of
categories including best reposado
tequila and best anejo tequila
she's more of a blanco girl but she said
on instagram quote for almost four years
i've been on a journey to create the
best tasting
tequila then i immediately checked her
age to make sure that she was twenty-one
how old is she
25. well so she so she's probably been
working on it for like eight years but
she had to say four
hundred percent that was my thought
that's a that's a good thing in good
investigative tools
after dozens of blind taste tests trips
oh i'm sorry
i clicked on a hyperlink after dozens of
blind taste tests trips to our
distillery ending
entering into world tasting competitions
anonymously and winning
three and a half years later i think
we've done and she wrote in the post
this is what all we've been drinking for
the last year
and i can't wait for everyone else to
get their hands on this to enjoy it as
much as we do
drink 818 coming soon so first of all i
mean the way that she's building it like
it sounds like it's a delicious tasting
tequila so
props for that but also i think a
kardashian
liquor brand is a wonderful new category
for them to expand into right that's
what i was thinking because there is so
much
overlap in their businesses like there's
multiple beauty multiple skin
clothes like it's all very niche it's
all very like
beauty and lifestyle beauty and
lifestyle and i think that
kendall first of all now like having her
own business it's like
fabulous outside of modeling because
modeling sadly does not last forever
it's a young woman's game which is just
the industry is just so [ __ ] up but
it is a new category and i think that
kendall's the perfect one for it because
she really is like the one who parties
the most she's like the free spirit
she's the single one
and i think this could be her ticket to
the next billionaire's club
i think this could be her ticket too i
think all aboard and i love when someone
finds their ticket
yeah i mean i'm still i've been
searching for mine
every day of my life but yeah no i think
this is her ticket onto the cover of
forbes just so they can take it back
because they're obsessed with the
kardashians and
labeling them billionaires and
non-billionaires and then taking about
self-made not self-made you know they
made that up and then took it back yeah
they're like fighting with themselves
yeah it's an internal struggle like the
kardashians don't care
don't care billion is a billion yeah
well
i i think in a year from now we'll be
watching this episode and we'll be like
wow we were so right we knew immediately
that it was going to make her a
billionaire yeah no just when she posted
this like i don't know if you guys felt
the same way toaster's like i just got a
good vibe i was like oh wow a bra
a move that makes sense you know it's
not like trying to
shoehorn it in like it just it doesn't
feel like a weird brand alignment like
it makes sense
natural next step it seems like couldn't
agree more i'm very excited for her and
really excited for the girl on tick tock
who
just like made headlines by being an
investigative journalist we'd love to
see that and are you excited to try the
tequila there is a blog though i don't
know if the blanco's award-winning but
no i i mean honestly at a certain point
in the night like i'll start drinking
toilet water like if it would get me
drunk so yeah um
i'll try anything send me a bottle cool
very exciting i wonder when it
launches launched to the public we'll
keep you posted yeah we will
okay next story more than 55 000 critics
quote cancel sia's
music amid autism backlash yes
music her movie not her music with the
capital m
not the name of the movie it's called
music the movie yeah sia's music the
movie
is hitting a very sour note with
thousands of online social justice
warriors says the new york post
oh this article is [ __ ] like shady
the singer songwriter's featural
feature directorial debut has already
been widely panned by critics
and otherwise concerned viewers but that
hasn't stopped the masses from rushing
to sign a petition
to have the film officially condemned by
the industry by the way of removing its
two 2021 golden globe award nominations
didn't realize it had been nominated for
golden globes
the change.org campaign has already
amassed 55 000 signatures since the
petition was launched
by allies of the autism community last
week 50 000 of which
came only in the last 24 hours related
petitions on the website have also
garnered substantial support
in music the movie starring best actress
golden globe nominee kate hudson
and leslie odom jr former dance mom star
maddie ziegler
plays a non-verbal autistic teenager
critics take aim primarily with the
casting of neurotypical ziegler
despite the available autistic actors
representatives for the film did not
immediately respond to the
post requests for comment right so we're
kind of living in this interesting age
right now
where in the last few years it's become
like
unacceptable to cast someone
in a movie or a tv show as something
they are not you know and i think a lot
of people
are split on this because it's like well
actors act so you can play a gay person
and not be gay you're an actor
and a lot of people are like well
there's a lack of opportunity for
actors with disabilities for gay actors
so why not use the opportunity for with
a gay role
or a role with someone with with
disabilities and and give that to
someone who
gets less opportunity so and i hear that
and to be honest i
wasn't sure how i felt about this
thing until i saw clips of maddie
playing
the autistic teenager and not that i
believe it was her intention at all but
it did
feel like like mocking yeah almost and
it felt like
very strange and like definitely
offensive to watch like i don't know how
all these people like watch the final
edit and was like yeah we should put
this out like
yeah it was uncomfortable to watch it
was uncomfortable to watch and i think
this is sort of reminding me of the
story reported on a few months ago with
the witches movie
which yeah pathway where again um
sort of mocking disabled people and a
missed opportunity for
you know an actress with or actor with
disabilities to have gotten that part
i don't think there are many parts for
written
with for characters with one arm you
know yeah
and also excuse me i'm about to sneeze
but the other thing i was going to say
oh because we were just having this
conversation
but um they're like many iconic movies
um where the main character is on the
spectrum or autistic and the character
who played
the the actor who played the character
was not autistic or on the spectrum
rainman is one of them yes um what's
eating gilbert grape
leonardo dicaprio's a younger brother
who is autistic and
it's just interesting like how much has
changed because we regard those as like
some of the best movies of all time and
i've seen both of them and they're
excellent
but that just can't happen today yeah
times change
yeah and this movie just seems like a
little out of touch
it does seem out of touch what's also
interesting about it we were just
talking about is it
it was filmed like so many years ago
right so now people
especially on tick tock since maddie's
like a teen is like well
who are we gonna blame here like do we
blame matty do we blame sia
and what the consensus from the kids on
tick tock is you know maddie was 14.
sia is her godmother she felt like she
was you know being protected sia has
always looked out for her like ever
since cia like plucked her from
obscurity on dance moms she has always
looked after i didn't even know that cia
was her godmother
um and this was filmed a while ago so
maddie was 14 and she had expressed that
she felt like really weird doing this
and they were like no it's fine it's
just art so i think the kids have
officially taken the blame
off of maddie ziegler um the thing is
while i do think that this is out of
touch and not
something i would watch like i'm not
going to sign a million petitions like i
just i'm not going to watch it like that
so that's a personal decision yeah i
think
that that's appropriate but um
we'll keep you posted this has been like
a story for a long time though like
because before the movie even came out
there was so much backlash like i saw
things
on like pop crave and just like on
twitter and i'm like what is this movie
i thought it was a music video this
whole time i didn't know sia was
in the business of making movies now yes
no we yeah it's been a long
a long time the whole thing yeah and now
it's finally out i think is why it's
become such a big story
yes okay our fifth and final story a
little royal news a little srn sad royal
news oh my god what is it
prince philip has been in princeville up
99
has been admitted to the hospital in
london after quote feeling
unwell you know what he'll be fine like
i feel like once a year we report on
this and
nobody bounces back better than prince
philip i really believe that the
duke of edinburgh was taken to king
edward the seventh hospital in london on
tuesday evening
on the advice of his doctor after
feeling unwell buckingham palace says in
a statement
he left windsor castle where he has been
staying with his wife queenie vibe
since november amid the coveted lockdown
late on tuesday and is suspected
to remain in the hospital for a few days
his royal highness
um is taking a precautionary measure on
the advice of his royal highnesses
doctor after feeling unwell
so this i feel like this like most
things could go either way
you know like definitely you know you
know precautionary measure
he's the prince we got the best
healthcare in the world right
or i don't know it's like when someone
coughs in a movie yeah and like
they took out their handkerchief and
there's like a little bit of blood like
that's how you know it's over
in the movies especially in like
old-timey london
someone coughs it's over but no i don't
know i just
i don't worry about prince philip like i
lay at night and i worry about a lot of
things and prince philip is not one of
them like
he is resilient he is 99 years old he
could probably outrun
me which is not saying much but i think
he's fine like he's just it's
precautionary
they have to take care of their royals
he just needed a quick trip to the
hospital he'll be fine
yeah okay it is not his time i also saw
a story that um
prince william is like quaking over this
oprah interview
because i think that you know they think
maybe harry and megan will spill the tea
honestly that just makes me want to
watch the interview of course
and i honestly don't think that they
will air any royal
dirty laundry rtl i'm definitely not but
um
i just thought that was an interesting
fact oh that is interesting i didn't see
that but now
me as well i'm feeling very excited for
the interview yeah march
13th i think it was seventh yeah could
could be either way
you know um could be neither it's very
true
thank you for those fast five stories i
felt as though they were very
informational and you definitely needed
to know that you definitely did
so um i guess we can get into our tv
recap now yes real housewives of dallas
was on last night their trip to austin
and it was full of you know giggly
moments but also a decent amount of
drama and i don't know about you
but i stand firmly on team deandra well
you do because you love deandra love and
i don't know how i feel
about them eavesdropping on deandra's
conversation where she's allowed to like
express her opinion
especially on a tv show here's the thing
as you get older you realize like
just because you're talking with your
friends like i guess you could
technically say yes i talk [ __ ] about
every single one of my friends just
because i express my feelings like
especially on a tv show where they
obviously needed that scene it was not
fair if carrie and cameron to stand
outside and then use it as a weapon
because
she was she didn't say anything bad she
was just saying how she felt right
so i don't know how i don't feel great
about that i don't think that's like
grounds for carrie to be so upset like
knowing how deandra personally feels and
i don't know what i would have done in
that situation i don't think i would
have listened the whole time because
like it does
feel wrong to listen to someone's like
private feelings and i believe it was
either tiffany or
um stephanie who said like to eavesdrop
and then use it as
um i forget what they said but it was
just really well said
like to use it as like a weapon and like
and and
i don't know what it was but it was
smart like it's just it's um it's it's
it's unfair territory like that doesn't
count yeah like we don't know carrie's
private feelings about deanna
right people are entitled to privacy i i
agree with that and i agree that it's
not
um fair to use in this in this fight and
i feel like
one she should have listened the whole
time you got the gist deandra still mad
and like take that to go and have a
private conversation with her
right not to like the way that she
brought it up at the table like
you know being back-handed and then
bringing it up in front of everyone like
if you really care about your friendship
which you're saying that you do like
that's not how you mend friendships and
by the way when deandra was in that room
complaining it was understandable like
her and carrie have been fighting for
months she makes a speech to tiffany
yeah like i would be upset too like
where's my apology and the thing is
in their their actual fight i do think
that they're both wrong like they both
are probably snooty they both don't ask
each other enough about what's going on
in their lives
but i think the way that they are both
reacting to
the fight makes me more team d'andra
like i just think carrie is so
like heavy-handed and so rude in the
things that she says like even though
it was weird as [ __ ] when tiffany
started crying like about
how she doesn't want her friends to
fight because it reminds her of her
parents fighting it was so random
carrie could have been a little bit
nicer when tiffany's sitting there
crying yeah
carrie's just very harsh
yeah and she's not my my cup of tea
anymore
i i feel that but it feels like the
women are siding with carrie yeah well
it feels like
tiffany is on team d'andra because
tiffany and deandra came in together and
i really respected tiffany for
taking the side when you're new in a
group it's easier to like go with the
flow
cameron is so annoyingly cameron is
always on the wrong side like whenever
um
i love everything about cameron except
when she gets involved in drama because
she's always on
choosing the wrong side well she's
always just sticking up for whoever
she's closest with blindly
leanne like she and she sticks with the
worst people yeah
leanne it also doesn't help that they're
all drunk because of course it makes it
impossible to have like rational
conversations so i do think that when
they wake up
tomorrow on the trip like they might
come to a better place but like they're
just drunk and emotional
yeah and not like no the only person who
was being rational was stephanie and
stephanie was not on either side i think
she was a little bit more sympathetic to
deandra
but she was really uh firmly like the
only one making sense
yeah i also just want to give a quick
shout out to like all of the looks for
this western night because
not only like do i love a country cowboy
theme but like i felt like everybody's
looks really
um represented to them like cameron's
pale pink boots were so stunning
stephanie was like wearing all light
blue like which is her color and she was
wearing the off-white cowboy boots that
say for walking on the side
but in blue and denim and then uh brandi
was just like every i just felt like
everyone's outfits really
represented them and the rock star bus
outfits were great too except i had a
huge problem with cameron westcott
because at first i'm like damn that's
really cool she had like a concert
t-shirt i know it was extra
i saw what you saw and then it was a
justin timberlake shirt no but like
that's cameron scott's definition of
rock and roll and like
we have no choice but to respect we have
no choice but we have no choice but to
respect the lack of taste
but we love her for it we really do
really do and i was just wondering like
do they sell that
t-shirt at the concession stand she made
it she made it she made the sleeves for
sure that's like really sweet
no it's that she blinked out her justin
timberlake concert t-shirt she's so
precious like i really have no problems
with her except that she's always
choosing the wrong side
no i know but like even still i think
the way that she handles herself
in these fights like she does she
doesn't get so
below the bell below the belt or in the
weeds like she has her side
but she's not butting her head into
things that don't
well i just agree i think she like butts
in a lot and just like makes annoying
points and like backs up like the most
rant like it just i actually don't like
the way that she fights at all but she
never says anything mean yeah and i have
to respect that because some of these
women go so below the belt
yeah um this blow up doll stuff is so
stupid like i can't
like i'm so there i i don't even want to
talk about it because i don't want to
give it to you
you brought it up the bus was so funny
like honestly great way to travel i'm
surprised the housewives haven't done
that more
except kim and kroy just did that with
their rv thing but it was really funny
and when they had to walk half a mile in
their shoes up to the house like i
wanted to cry
harry's heels were so high huge i was in
shock that was a really long walk that
house is amazing gotta go
gotta go gotta go that house is amazing
like one of weirdly like my favorite
houses i've seen
i agreed like it had everything it had
every vibe everything
jacuzzi like just everything vibes lake
vibes usually not the same vibe
yeah chainsaw masker vibes next week
yeah it was really it was actually a
great episode and i think the trip is
off to a great start and i think it'll
be great deandra's obviously not going
home
jeremy gave her some very sound advice i
love jeremy i also thought it was so
funny and like a cute friend moment when
tiffany gave
deandra b12 shots yes yes and i also so
tiffany's journey um from last week to
this week has been interesting and also
like from the beginning i feel like she
was like a really well liked in a fan
favorite off the bat i feel like last
week we were like okay you're
it's it took a turn it took a turn but i
feel like she's
super self-aware and yeah i really like
her change and attitude this week where
it's like i'm gonna try and push myself
out of my comfort zone
i just i feel like in her interview
she's really honest and self-aware and
those are two qualities i really respect
so even when
in the moment her actions like you know
aren't
totally perfect she always owns up to it
and makes a change for the next time and
i
have no choice but to respect and
understand i agree
um okay that was our tv recap thank you
so much for joining and now we're gonna
do our deer toaster segment which is
brought to you
by hum nutrition formulated by experts
and rigorously tested
each unique hum nutrition supplement
packs a combo of potent
clean and clinically proven ingredients
designed for specific goals like clear
skin
improved sleep hair growth balanced mood
and healthier body
to help boost your well-being in the
ways you need it most take their quick
quiz and get individualized product
recommendations
from their team of registered dietitians
to help bring your skin
body hormones and mood into balance with
home nutrition
so i love a personalized quiz here
because vitamins and supplements people
have different uses for them i know for
me like i
really want to target headaches my
memory and just general fatigue
and that's not the case for everyone so
i like taking a a quiz on
homenutrition.com
so i know like what i'm being sent is
specifically for me and you know i know
you wanted to use it for like your hair
and and your skin
yes and also for energy and all those
great things that supplements can
provide home nutrition is the brand
some of our favorite products from there
are the hair sweet hair where the which
are the gummies
that boost your body's ability to mean
healthy maintain healthy vibrant hair
and support hair growth and then we also
love the glow sweet glow gummies
they're vegan also and they help keep
moisture locked into your skin and
glowing throughout the day
so if you have any needs that you think
a supplement or a vitamin
could help with head over to
homnutrition.com and use the code toast
for 15 off your first order so again
they have a flexible subscription
options and very chic packaging and it's
super easy to get
started and stay on top of your daily
dose so make sure to go to hum
nutrition dot com the code is toast you
can get 15
15 off your first order of 29 or more
love it
okay dear toasters your toasters is our
advice segment if you ever want to write
in and get some decent advice from us
dear toasters gmail.com is the email we
will always keep it anonymous
hi claudia and jackie love you both so
much and thanks for adding much needed
humor to my days while i'm working from
home
truly britain youtube truly brightened
my day thanks
i'm currently writing this under the
covers in my bed alone may i add on
valentine's day
from this you would probably believe i'm
single but i've actually been dating my
boyfriend for two and a half years he's
not very mushy but the past two
valentine's days he's taken me to dinner
given me roses and chocolates and has
spent the whole day with me
this year we decided to do dinner on the
13th which is a saturday which i was
totally okay with
but to my disappointment he didn't show
any appreciation for me today on actual
valentine's day
no flowers chocolates dumb instagram
posts or anything
i don't want to sound like a brat but it
makes me feel extremely underappreciated
and i just spent nearly two thousand
dollars
to go away for a trip for his birthday
on top of his birthday presents
and a valentine's day gift to make
matters worse he barely talked to me all
day because he's been running around
trying to find a headset for his
playstation
i don't want venus to floor roses but i
thought maybe gas station flowers would
be okay
for his budget i really don't want to
start a fight but i don't want to come
off as underappreciate
under appreciative but i'm really sad
and feeling let down
let me know how you two queens would
handle this if ben and zach pulled some
[ __ ] like this
from valentine's day who
communication is key girl like you have
to speak up yeah
he's never gonna know you're just
sitting under your covers he's probably
like she has her period
yeah you're gonna like stew and make
yourself upset more upset as opposed to
like this is one of those
rare times where getting it off your
chest is quite helpful
put it on someone else you know yeah
it's a burden like let him unburden you
right and then he will obviously
apologize because i he doesn't seem like
a bad person and i don't think he ever
thought that he made you feel that way
and then you will feel so much better so
i would just go to him you know
civilly civil sweet just hurt like
hi um i had such a great time saturday
night i just was a little bummed maybe
like one tear you know strategically
placed
yeah let's get that um candace
folded up tissue and like hit the
corners of your eye yep like that
can't like set just say i had such a
great time saturday and i was just a
little bummed because i was
really excited to spend valentine's day
with you and um i've seen you all day
and like didn't get me any flowers like
what the [ __ ] going on
i didn't really i was sniff i didn't
feel very special and
you know i love you so much and i uh i
just it's rival i'm sad
yeah no communication is key you're not
saying anything crazy and
if he's a normal human being he'll
understand and if he's not
bye and then like leave your computer
open to venus to floor
shopper maze.com yes
you know this is this is not a terrible
problem to have communication is key in
a relationship so you got to just
communicate and i know it's hard yeah no
it it is hard but it gets easier the
more times you do it
right and then you're just expressing
your disappointment about everything
yeah try not to be like such a nagging
that's like
my cross to bear in this lifetime is
like not being an aggie wife but like
having to get things off my chest but
it's like
literally you left the freezer open two
nights in a row like everything inside
melted and i had to clean up all the
chicken juice like that's terrific no i
know and it's just like it's one thing
after another i'm like put your
playstation run away i just feel like a
mom at some times and like that's my
cross to wear
personally yeah no i remember
communicating the first time i was like
disappointed in something that like zach
did or didn't do in our relationship and
i was like making myself sick with how
to handle it right
and ultimately i decided to just let him
know how i was feeling
and just overnight the stomach ache just
absolved
yeah no you're right and then it was on
him to go and fix it and
he did and he did all right next up hi
jackie and claudia i discovered the
morning toasting quarantine and since
i've listened
every day love you both i am 23 and my
brother's 27.
back in march of 2020 peak quarantine my
parents decided to drop the bomb that my
dad was not me nor my brother's
biological father
they couldn't get pregnant due to my dad
having bad swimmers and decided to go
with a sperm donor to have my brother
when they decided to have me they used
the same donor my parents told
absolutely no one about using the donor
cue my identity crisis i decided to do
23andme ancestry and health to learn
about any health concerns and about
where i'm from
i know there was a chance discovering
family members but that's the kind of
stuff that happens in movies
my results came in and i have one
relative my biological grandmother
she connected with me and her buyer read
i have no grandchildren so i would love
to meet you and your half siblings
three so far then a weird part saying my
biological father would need to meet me
first
she direct messaged me saying i'm so
thrilled to know you exist and i can't
wait to learn more about you
i'm in shock i don't mind chatting with
her and learning some family history but
right now i have no interest in learning
about my sperm father
i can't even imagine seeing a picture of
him oh my god that would be so creepy
i'm happy for his donation but that's it
my brother has zero interest
learning more and doesn't want me to
share anything about him i messaged her
back thanking her for reaching out but i
said i needed time to process
what would you guys do what would you
want to know more about her learn about
sperm father meet them someday
what questions would you ask should i
ask how connected how she connected with
the three other half siblings
i don't know what to do please help from
a toaster with a huge family secret she
can't tell anyone before we dive in
i just want to say like one or two years
ago we went on like a whole tangent
about how 23andme is like ruining the
anonymity of sperm donors and this is
the exact case
because as a sperm donor it is your
right to never get named or anything
so where legally does 23 and me
i don't know that's really that's tough
it's unchartered territory
and so i don't think there's a right or
wrong way to handle it obviously do what
feels best to you but
in just hearing this what i think i
would do i understand that
why and how you actually have no
interest in meeting your sperm donor
father and i don't think that i would
either
there's no real connection there and i
think it really complicates things but
the grammar but something about this
precious grandma who doesn't have any
grandchildren and like
you it just feels like so beautiful so
what i would say to her
if this is how you're feeling i would
say wow this is so amazing like it's so
nice to meet you
um i would i would be interested in
getting to know you
i just don't feel the same way about
my quote father yeah so if that if
meeting him
is the only way i can meet you then i
would say no thank you
but if you are interested in pursuing a
relationship with me
that's something i would be interested i
would also i mean for me personally i
don't know if she wants to get all the
like half siblings together who were
like part of this sperm
donors um club club i personally want
wouldn't feel it uh necessarily like an
obligation
to meet them but i don't know something
about this gmat like
on 23andme looking for grandkids like
but don't do anything you're not
comfortable with so just make it very
clear like i would love to meet you i
have like no interest in meeting
your son and if that's cool with you
great if not buy like yeah
you don't do anything you're not
comfortable with grandma doesn't make
the rules like you do
so 100 don't let her push you around
this also does sound like a little
exciting
you know this sounds like a novel like
let us know how it ends we'd love an
update from you please yes good luck
that's like that's crazy that's where
you know we're living in the future you
know
all right third and final hello to the
most beautiful stunning and smart ladies
wow thank you both for brighting my
morning and making me laugh harder than
i thought was possible while listening
to a podcast
i realized that i would be rdh if i
didn't write in for some advice
so here i am my boyfriend is an absolute
p john
we recently bought a home and have been
together for three years after moving in
together dating long distance through a
deployment and even after the quarantine
we remain together and stronger than
ever
but after three years he has yet to post
a picture of us on facebook or instagram
i don't know we've had professional
photos done and so many
cute options to show ourselves and our
and show off our dog
but he won't post any of them i've
recently spoken to him about how it
bothers me and his reasoning was not
wanting to google
google to know anything about his life
he's very private online and has only
posted once in the last three years
i understand his concern and it's hard
to argue because he's he is a cyber
crime agent in the fbi
wow this man just like sounds like
everything the only reason i've been
able to come up with
is because it would just make me happy
my question is am i overreacting is this
just my own millennial self making a
bigger deal and caring too much about
social media
yes signed a possibly dramatic toaster
if you had told me a homeboy was like
active on social media playing farmville
you know
like doing all these things like lit
facebook account
and not posting you i would have been
like oh this is shady homeboy doesn't
post on instagram like
period end of discussion like it's not a
big deal no and he works in cyber crimes
like you could hear
he knows something he doesn't it sounds
like he's the king and we're not sorry
we're the sorry people like having all
of our information up i think that you
have a treasure on your hands
who's looking out for all of you and
your well-being yeah the fact that he's
not like putting it out to the public
it's like
it's like we're playing checkers and
he's playing chess no being
dating this man is like playing chess
with bobby fischer like he's a genius no
it's like being married to bobby fisher
yes you know this is such a blessing you
have like
and i'm so glad you wrote in because
sometimes when you're in a situation you
can't see outside perspectives and
we don't know you we don't know your
boyfriend but i feel so strongly that
like my fresh perspective is right like
you should be so grateful that you don't
have a thirst monster for
like a boyfriend or a husband who
doesn't care about social media it's
such a blessing
it's so fresh it's so rare he's
literally the definition of a precious
gem
of a man because he's rare yeah the
precious gem
i think he's looking out for all of you
and the fact that
he doesn't post at all like makes him
not posting you less insulting like you
know he's your man
if you have other reasons to like worry
about his intentions
please write back in and let us know of
those but up until this point it sounds
like everything he does
is consistent in his line of thinking
you know what i mean it's not like
he thinks says one thing does another
thinks one thing but over here
does something different like this is
who he is and what he believes and
everything that he does is in line with
that i don't think you have an issue
no you not only do not have an issue you
have a gift like you wrote in being like
i have this problem and it turns out you
actually don't have a problem you have a
surplus of blessings
and you should be grateful yeah so go
give him a big kiss
so those were our deer toasters if you
have written in and we have read your
prompt on
air this week or any week previously and
you have an update please
update us write another email and just
put update in the subject line and we'll
do our best to get it on air
and if you have any quandaries any
queries any problems email us
deartoasters gmail.com and
that's our show our merch is now
available at shopmorningtoast.com
the redheads collection and the hyund
collection
both available until supply runs out
so check it out check it out
shopmorningtoads.com we will see you
guys tomorrow have a fabulous day thank
you so much for listening to the morning
toast the millennium morning show where
we deliver the fast facts stories say
you need to know every monday through
friday and youtube so if you're watching
us on youtube please feel free to
subscribe
and give this video a thumbs up we're
also available as a podcast anywhere
podcast can be found so it's spotify
itunes or public radio i already cast
watch all the places where we listen to
the podcast find us good morning chelsea
faster review about our beautiful
stunning and smart we are hope you have
an amazing day amazing hump day make
sure to hump someone you love
specifically your dog and we'll see you
tomorrow
bye